pure cost from from what I lost you know
investing in advertising thinking this
was going to work was about fifty to
sixty thousand dollars so he offered me
a free iPad and I got that and it's an
expensive iPad when you think about it I
mean from a certain perspective it's a
very expensive iPad but yeah yeah so he
used his the name of his former company
to claim it's some accrediting body
[Laughter]
welcome to coffee Salette today we have
Levi and he wants to talk to you guys
about teaching English as a foreign
language and how he got scammed by Jimmy
krendler right Jimmy Kringle
Jimmy Crangle angler
it's the Crangle ooh that's a good
nickname yeah so just jump in Levi I
mean let's start maybe broad terms how
much what was the impact of getting
involved with Jimmy krinkle the Crangle
oh that's a good question man as the
impact long-term it's hard to say
because I lost so much an opportunity
cost but just pure cost from from what I
lost you know investing in advertising
thinking this was going to work was
about fifty to sixty thousand dollars so
brutal that is brutal
I think it's a good cautionary tale the
reason I'm having you on is I often
think these are good cautionary tales
for anyone who thinks that they have
something that feels too good to be true
obviously you didn't get involved in
this thinking that you would lose that
amount of money walk us through how you
got there and how you had that much to
begin with I think that's that's
interesting I was an English teacher in
China for three and a half years I
started in 2015 in May
okay yeah yeah and yeah I had I had a I
didn't have much money at the time but I
saved it up over the next three and a
half years teaching I got better jobs
and I got I got a teaching certificate
so I was a professional teacher and got
a job at an international school and I
also made a little bit of that money
about twenty thousand dollars from
trading cryptocurrency so yeah I at that
point in my life I was like I'm ready to
just move back to the United States I
don't like it here anymore I don't want
to teach I don't want to be in China so
that's amazing because I think for a lot
of people they want to go abroad and
they have this like very big fantasy
about what going abroad could mean and
teaching abroad is one of those one of
those ways people consider doing it what
was your experience with that
yeah it was exciting you know I had the
same idea when I started a it was this
big fantasy like I was just gonna travel
the world and make money doing it
it was great you know so the illusion
kind of wore off as time went on because
I was having to deal with all this
bureaucratic stuff being a foreigner in
China and it just didn't seem like the
people would treat me like a normal
person because I was a foreigner to them
so anyway I was thinking about getting
into this business because you know it
seemed like a good investment for me I'd
been around I had had some experience in
that industry hold on let's back up
let's again make sure to clarify what
business are you getting into cuz we
haven't gotten into that what if Jimmy
crank calls business so you are teaching
English as a foreign language in China
what's so should I describe his business
model yes okay so the idea was he called
this a franchise so he was selling a
part of his business basically and I
think this is a little different from
your normal run-of-the-mill guru like
you usually do the fakers because he's
actually claiming he has a working
business model
so yeah the deal was I would sell his
temple courses and temple is an acronym
for teaching English as a foreign
language so there these courses you can
do to prepare yourself to ostensibly
teach English overseas in basically any
country I was like yeah okay that sounds
legit because you know I knew this could
work I knew people made money doing it
and but I didn't know this guy of course
so and the deal was I would get 80% of
the profits for all of the courses sold
plus another commission if I recruited
other franchisees that's such a high
percentage of the Commission eighty
percent I've never heard of a commission
that high I was just just went up and
down wildly like sometimes it would be
20,000 40,000 for the franchise fee and
then he's sorry how much did you pay for
the franchise the franchise was thirty
thousand dollars for me
hey and what did you get just the
promise that I would make 80 percent of
the profits so you got no physical good
you got no physical good for thirty
thousand dollars just more like Ashley I
think that's why he offered some of
these other perks because it's like
there's nothing physical to this so he
offered me a free iPad and I got that
and it's an expensive iPad when you
think about it
I mean from a certain perspective it's a
very expensive iPad but yeah yeah yeah
free and also also okay so I want to get
into some of the PERT co-author which
was offered to like I had to fly out I
had to play pay for my plane ticket to
get out to Thailand where he lived and
he would offer me this free TEFL course
I thought this was actually his TEFL
course it was live in class so I would
go attend that temple course on the
tropical island of Koh Samui and I did
so it turns out he wasn't even
associated with that temple course he
just paid for me to be in there I guess
what and why were you going cuz you
already were teaching as you had already
been a teacher of English as a foreign
language for three years you went to
experience what it would be like to sell
that product or what I wanted to take
advantage of what he was offering me you
know cuz he was like you can go to Koh
Samui which is a really nice place to be
I'm like a vacation it was a nice time
you know I'm not gonna lie I got
something but it's not worth what I paid
it I paid for the business that's what I
was in it for and the business was you
would sell for him his course and you
would get eighty percent of the profits
you know I think a lot of people
listening including myself are gonna
think that sounds more like an affiliate
link than it does a franchise franchise
yeah given that's probably not the legal
term but that's the word he used it's a
franchise sounds like yeah it sound it
sounds like you're getting something
whereas what you're really getting is is
kind of an affiliate deal I guess yeah
and then and and how is this pitch to
you I mean you wouldn't spend thirty
thousand dollars if you thought it was
uh you know wouldn't make you some money
why did you think it would make you so
much money I don't know it was one of
those Facebook ads that I clicked on I
never would have given it a second look
but because I because I knew about this
fake guru stuff I was kind of naive at
the time but this guy offered something
tangible and I had some experience with
it so it's like this might actually work
and I'm sure he said it's basically
guaranteed if it doesn't work you'll get
your money back it's like well oh dude
that those promises aren't worth
anything never guys when you see a
money-back guarantee it's never worth
the paper it's printed on son how much
money is sometimes it's honored
sometimes it's not and the guys in where
to Thailand yeah yeah what are you gonna
do right so okay
okay so yeah offers you a money-back
guarantee guaranteed to work and he's
basically pitching you the laptop
lifestyle I'm guessing in the Facebook
ad yeah yeah like the digital Nomad
thing seductive man it's so seductive
yeah they all use the same tactic so you
know I've come to learn this over the
years it's just I don't know so okay so
you and so you have it you decide all
right I want to do this and you have
thirty thousand dollars to spend because
you've been saving all this money right
right yeah I've been teaching yeah but
you were saving that so you could land
on your feet when you wanted to do
something else right yeah exactly
you know I I had this idea that I was
gonna go home and start real estate
investing in real estate and that was
what I wanted to do since before I left
for China so that's probably what I
should have done it's just I could have
gone home and bought a house free and
clear and I'd be I'd be good set you
know I'd be set but I decided no I'm
gonna invest this right now well I have
this opportunity because it was just
right in my face and I thought you know
I thought it would work so it would be a
good transition for me once
once I was out of China and living in
the US and I didn't really know what to
do in the US and I kept having these
creeping thoughts like what if this
doesn't work and I have nothing left and
that's essentially what happened when I
got back to the US because it cost so
much to run this business yeah yeah how
much did you have in savings if you
don't mind me asking before leaving
China and starting this course and then
how much did you have after if you can
Paul Park I I
I calculated it somewhere around eighty
to eighty five thousand dollars in
savings a lot of money that's a good job
saving oh yeah yeah I didn't have any
debt when I left so that really helped
but so I was able to save and then at
the end you know the thirty thousand
took a good chunk of it and after that I
spent like a year trying to hire people
to do the marketing for me because I
didn't have any experience in this kind
of thing oh you gave this a real shot
like you really tried to yeah this thing
like it was it just it's just gonna
throw money at it until it worked oh my
gosh so it's so interesting okay so
sometimes people really realize like
early on for some reason they're really
fooled at the outset and then they
realized early on oh it's a scam I'm not
gonna spend any time on it but very few
people but what I like actually kind of
appreciate that you really gave this a
shot because now you can definitively
talk about whether it's a scam where
it's not because you have a real you've
given it yeah
tens of thousands of dollars I had these
doubts you know in my mind throughout
the whole period I was like you know
maybe I'm just maybe I just suck at this
but I hired the best people I could and
I actually got it caught in up in
another scam while I was doing it for a
professional online marketer who's doing
Facebook ads I got like a few posts on
my facebook and
nothing else that was it
now Levi's log off Facebook dude I think
give me the log on Facebook I think
Facebook's the start of all your
troubles okay you know what you're right
yeah you can't you can't believe what
you see on Facebook man they don't know
they don't monitor any of that stuff Wow
everybody's going up work okay
okay up work so he's an internet
marketer Facebook market or whatever
yeah and after that I actually found
some guys who are pretty good and
they're the ones who keep me off that
this was all a scam you know in a
certain way you know did they did they
outright tell you that no they they did
they had no idea what I was doing they
thought it would work too because I
didn't I didn't really prep them on this
but it was like okay you you you've run
my ads on Facebook um you know pay the
marketing costs and I'll pay you your
fee it was $1,000 a month to hire them
and then I was gonna spend 2,000 a month
on ads because I was going big you know
Wow but yeah that's a lot of money yeah
so I had these professional ads made
that was another cost and then had them
run on Facebook for a few months and the
thing is I actually got to sales in the
beginning I got credited with two sales
so I was like yeah you know maybe this
could actually work so I'll keep trying
this for a little while and then the
winter came and that the holidays and
everything things were slowing down and
they had told me this according to their
business model things would be really
low in December so I was like I'm just
gonna take a break for now so I put the
whole operation on hold in November
until the end of January and January
2019 or 2018 2018 okay yeah then
November is when I flew out to Thailand
and I met Jimmy Kringle
what was that like a man hard to
describe its you know yeah this this air
like it like a guru but once I was there
I was like you know how could this be a
scam I'm actually here he's paying for
my hotel room he's physically I don't
know where my camera just went out of
focus he's physically yeah right how
could this scam justification you know
in my mind he's standing right in front
of me right yeah which I never thought
somebody would scam you to your face
that's just like oh yeah something that
happens far away no no no no this game
you to your face
computer anyway man anyway okay so and
at this point you hadn't seen much
success did you bring that up with him
yeah I was trying to build a website I
also hired somebody to build a website
for me and and all of this is to
redirect affiliate traffic to him
exactly right and okay and how is this
supposed to make you a hundred K a year
I mean you'd have to get so many sales
right I the way I calculate was like 15
sales a month would put me in the profit
zone so that's a lot of sales I mean how
many English teaching positions are
there versus how many advertisers for
teaching yeah this is a foreign length
and the demand was was huge in this
industry like it was a 10 billion dollar
market or something I don't know
I mean I mean it doesn't pass the smell
test is possible it's possible my
concept of how huge the teaching English
foreign language certificate market is
but in a lot of people who would I did
it you know sure no no I've no doubt
that people do it I mean I'm just saying
that that is a yeah it's a gigantic
scale but but the idea was go ahead
sorry sorry go ahead
well I could have taken the cue from my
friend at like in China he was the first
guy who got me into China and found me
some jobs that was his role and he
warned me from the outset that this was
a scam like you never make any money
doing this stuff but I didn't listen to
him you know this was after I already
paid $30,000 I thought well then of
course he didn't looks like I could've
told you yeah yeah yeah if you're if you
already spent thirty thousand dollars
you're not gonna listen to the naysayers
right I could have saved I still could
have saved myself a bunch of money
though yeah I mean it sounds like you
spent tens of thousands of dollars after
that on Facebook ads hiring a team all
this stuff so when did you realize okay
this is a gigantic scam and in some ways
this is seriously screwed up your future
plans yeah yeah absolutely you know I
couldn't just jump into real estate like
I thought I would do but um you know I
I've had to get it another pick another
career path which I'm doing now I'm
going into aviation maintenance and you
know that's going okay so far at the
moment I realized this was all a scam it
it was after you know I wish I'd
realized this before I had gone to his
mastermind training event in Bangkok is
that I could have I could have I could
have blown the whole thing wide open but
but after that I was still under the
impression that I was going to make some
money and he like addressed some of my
concerns while we were there he's like
okay we're just gonna send it to his
webpage that he had already made and
we're gonna use my special affiliate
link and then so I kept it I started
doing that again it started the
operation back up in January late
January and through February I got one
sale and one more sale in the beginning
and then nothing for the rest of the
month so how is this possible he's like
he I did phone calls with and he's like
this is gonna pick up gradually as you
go but you know after about a month I
was like there's nothing and he was like
no no just keep going you know you you
have to do it for at least three months
and you know the meanwhile my team was
telling me you know we had some good
metrics on Facebook Ads but there's just
no sales right people work people are
clicking and they are actually buying
which is a good indicator that the
product you know if you can get people
in front of your product and they're
consistently not buying that says more
about the product because the
advertisement just to get them in the
door and so if you were getting out the
door in the door you were doing your
part and then if they weren't getting
sales conversions weren't happening
that's totally on crank ler yeah yeah
there's there's another important point
because he was a there's there's from
all indications from what I can tell he
was stealing commissions he was stealing
credit for these sell sale where she was
because otherwise he'd have to give you
80% of the profits exactly they're like
what's the point why would he do that
I didn't realize the stupid you know but
yeah so so the indication was that I
knew some of these people who I was
selling to it was like I want to clarify
I don't know whether he stole
commissions I don't want to say he stole
Commission's I don't know this is that's
Levi's accusation there you
yeah no no and I have no idea I can
backed it I could have it sound like a
hundred percent certain but you know it
to me it was obvious and I'd verified
this with other franchisees at the time
it's like I knew some of these people I
was selling to and they said they
clicked on my link the way Jimmy said
would work if anybody ever clicked on my
link I would get credit for them even if
they clicked on a different link later
if they ended up buying the product and
they've clicked on your link first yeah
at the credit I would get credit and you
were not getting credit no like I to
some of these people they said they
clicked on my link and they bought the
course Jimmy Bogle and that that person
had actually purchased a course I was
like they got the link from me first so
how did I not get credit for that
that's the unless they somehow found it
on unless they never clicked on my link
and then they went and somehow found the
other link on Facebook somewhere let me
ask you how indicative of this is it is
this two other teaching English as a
foreign language course because
obviously Jimmy krinkle I think most
people haven't heard of them he's just
some guy some [ __ ] what you're kind of
characterizing as a shyster III won't I
won't make my own personal character
judgments against him but there are a
lot of people in this industry that are
kind of similar would you say or yeah it
varies you know most of the TEFL courses
have no backing whatsoever there's no
accreditation but schools will still
accept it as some form of Education to
MIT to submit to their government to say
that we were allowed to have foreign
teachers working here so what would you
recommend people do if they're getting
into it would you say don't go to a
teaching certification at all just say
hey go through the cheapest one you can
because there none of them are credited
I don't want to say that you know
because they're there actually there's
like one legitimate person one
legitimate horse that I can think of if
you don't mind me what's that go ahead
the International Temple Academy okay so
that was there I I did that through them
first when I went there and they gave me
some you know I had to do some practicum
mm-hm just like real teaching and submit
evidence of that and it was you know it
helped a little bit so there's a they
had some educational standards there but
these other courses they're just
completely online you you click through
a few oh so it's just it slides
yeah it's review videos right yeah yeah
so so that's the idea but they're but
outside of these like this very maybe
small group of legit sources there are a
lot of people trying to do something
similar to Jimmy Crangle where it's like
just a quick and fast certification that
doesn't mean anything
didn't you say that he said he was
accredited or something like that yeah
yeah actually that's a good point I have
some screenshots here by the way guys
you cannot find this anymore because
this website has been taken down we'll
get into that in a second but just for
you guys looking play the English
dot-org no longer exists
for what for reasons we'll get into but
this is a screenshot I guess you took
before it got shut down yep okay yeah
just to to verify some of this stuff so
yeah this is actually I TEFL dot-org
over here on the I don't know his site
it is for you but it's the left on my
side yeah he has the same the same TEFL
logo at the bottom there that the blue
logo
okay yep right yeah that's also on his
old eye TEFL dot-org page can you see
that got it god I got it got it got it
got it yeah yeah I see that like that
temple logo right what what is that logo
supposed to be is it like a negotiation
this is the ITF logo he also used that
on English and then at the bottom of the
page it says accredited by the
International TEFL Organization who is
the International temple organization
that's this one so he used his the name
of his former company to claim it's some
accrediting body oh that's uh that's
that's pretty bold oh yeah here stop
sharing for a second okay so so he
started an old company then had a new
company and said his new company's
accredited by his hook exactly exactly
it was a big trust him exactly yeah and
you didn't realize this until much later
I'm guessing yeah I realized this at
some point during the whole thing and I
was starting to have doubts you know so
you started realizing it was bad your
sales weren't coming in and that's when
you is that when you jump ship basically
yeah i when when I heard the difference
between what Jimmy was saying and what
my marketers was saying I was like this
is not a good sign so that was it for me
I was like okay I'm gonna call it you
guys can go you know no complaints
against the marketing the the business
that I'd hired is just there was I could
tell that this was all Jimmy's fault at
that point you'd kind of gotten
hoodwinked by the promise of yeah no I
don't I don't want to say it was always
followed I'm partially responsible to of
course but sure sure but I mean mostly
Jimmy's fault though right
and so at that point you get really
angry I'm assuming yeah yeah really
angry and I emailed him back and it was
like back and forth I was like you know
you know about that that promise you
made me I mentioned this in our meeting
in Bangkok and he was like yeah you'll
get it but you'll have to step away from
the franchise what I promise the money
back the money back guarantee okay
he was like yeah you'll get that and
then I was like hey you know about that
thing you said is like it's like okay I
think I'll I'll cash in on that yeah cuz
you hadn't made any money so he should
give you back your money right right and
that was the whole deal you know if I
make less than $50,000 a year in the
first year he said I'd get my money back
that's what they all say man that they
tell you that's what they tell you so
you believe it so that you think okay
this is risk-free or assures you that
there's basically no downside that's the
biggest scam in the book yeah okay and
then you try to exercise it yeah yeah
exactly and then he's like okay the
board is going to have a meeting about
this and we're going to tell you our
decision later what board I don't know
there was no board there's no limb here
and say that there probably was no board
involved it was probably Jimmy Crangle
or krendler go going up hmm do I want to
give back $30,000 no all in favor
myself right right and I got the email
back the response saying we noted the
following they gave me all these reasons
like with their business the reasons it
was something like you didn't try hard
enough we gave you everything we didn't
and then you didn't do it for three
months like we said there it is there it
is right so we're not on it for more
than three months yeah definitely well I
mean I hadn't advertised continuously
for three months because you had been
like trying it
hiring a new team trying it hiring a new
team stuck it on sore eyes great rubber
alright so he was like no you got to do
this continuously for three months what
didn't ah I've never in the stipulations
you know of course not
I feel bad I feel bad for you and I feel
bad for anyone I think people assume
that because most refund policies we
have an expectation in America that they
usually are what they say they are like
if you go back to like Walmart and say
hey this wasn't what I thought or what I
wanted you could just get a refund
there's this really frictionless
experience of refunds in an American
culture that makes you think that
everybody who says there's a refund it
is what they say it is and let me be
clear with you guys it is not what they
say it is with a lot of these internet
markers that's a good point
and you know this was I think that's
true of the Western world in general
because but there were people from
England Australia all over the place
South Africa investing in this franchise
okay so it wasn't just me you know but
that's that's good that's good you were
hey hey you weren't the only one yeah
that's bad actually we don't want a
crank ler isn't it no no I maybe you
don't understand how bad it is because I
think this guy probably scammed people
out of millions of dollars I don't know
for sure how much it was but it was
definitely more than 20 people and it
was and he said he limited to 50 in the
contract at one time I was like we're
not gonna have any more than 50
franchisees and it later video that's
always a lie that's always a lie when
people say hey Liberty class space they
wanted to sound exclusive but the second
2:51 person wants to pay $30,000 I
you all those little dreams of a small
class size they disappear they always do
look at sir well you don't know him but
there's this guy Sir Roger of all he was
this computer science guy he said I'm
starting a course it's gonna be 500
people lo and behold he created two
different slack groups that were each
500 people large because he didn't want
to tell the other group that he like
wanted more people
his course to make more money yeah no
that's never that's it the greed takes
over you always end up yeah it was in
the contract though and mean anything
it's in the contract
we have a I anyway it's sorry I've got a
register I don't want a J I'm just
trying to emphasize how how I don't know
how brutal this was because right you
know he claimed that there were several
times we were watching him over the
course of you know after I had already
given up and I was like now pursuing him
basically and we started this Facebook
group but we were watching him he said
that there was to be clear this Facebook
group that's like Jimmy Crangle victims
or whatever you wanna call yes yes okay
go ahead so we were watching him he said
a couple of separate times hurry up
these franchise licenses are going to
run out in this November forever and
then he said that again later oh yeah
false scarcity yeah right yeah yeah the
old Dan locks prices are gonna go up to
$10,000 from $2,500 if you don't act now
right so yeah now I mean Clark just
classic stuff you know what's
interesting is that I hope and I hope
people who watch this channel on a
regular basis start to get the sense
that you see the same thing showing up
again and again and I don't think of it
as repetitive I think of it as
illustrative of the fact that this
industry is not original everybody's
copying from each other and all the
tactics they use to convince people are
the same they're the same used in
different ways this like false scarcity
thing of like the it's about to expire
you got to join now it's old as time
it's just as old as time it's what it is
right and people kept joining and you
know eventually we got to the point
where where we were leaving enough bad
reviews online that it was starting to
affect his business he was like hey you
guys are affecting my business like oh
sorry
and then
yeah you know he offered us a refund he
offered me a refund first and that was
sometime in 2019 July June July and then
contingent on what sorry contingent on
what Oh Oh contingent on the fact that I
stopped harassing him stop or delete
your previous post as well well I wasn't
gonna delete my previous post at that
point I was past that so he had already
asked for that at one point like I'm
going to sue you for libel and
defamation if you if you don't take this
down the first time I took it down the
second time I was like no you just got
to make good no idea have you ever you
how much of you watched of coffee Zilla
just like one or two videos or like just
like like half a video probably five or
six videos okay okay okay well it's just
funny to me that because he's checking
every box right now you have no idea how
funny this is because every guru as soon
as they start getting bad reviews their
first option is like oh she's in desist
letter I'm gonna sue you for libel and
slander yeah yeah and then he signs off
the email in plain text like I am a
lawyer right no no he didn't say that
literally but like he's like this name
while your plain text there's nothing
there's no logo there there's no company
that I can check or verify and it has an
at English dorg email address all right
so so after that he promised that by
October I would get all of the money
back I mean that wasn't the part of the
he signed an agreement like a settlement
agreement he called it and I was
supposed to stop defaming him online and
stuff and then it was like $250 a month
he maybe two payments of $500 bimonthly
and then by October the third payment
was due he was late on the first payment
you know but and then then in October he
was like okay because you're so upset
I'm going
give you all your money back in October
there's like okay I'll accept that you
know because I have to wait I can't just
not wait and see what happens there's I
have no other option so right he's got
you he's telling ya yeah and then you
know a few days before the date the due
date runs it comes around he's like you
know because you contacted one of my
franchisees something or whatever he's
like I'm not gonna pay you was like how
predictable and that was the point at
which I gave up on it you know but on
getting a refund you know emotionally I
was like this is over yeah but yeah
later we as a group we collectively
started you know pushing and pushing
back trying to expose this guy online
for what he is we're just telling our
story you know he can't stop us from
doing that right and you know there were
so many of us so it had a real impact he
was like okay I'm gonna pay you back all
of your money you just got to stop and
that was like two hundred and eighty
seven thousand dollars that he you know
this oh just in this group that had
joint voluntarily joined the group right
he said he's gonna pay all of these
people back by the way this isn't the
number of people who have gotten scammed
collectively this is just the number of
people who have been found that like
voluntarily join this group okay that's
a lot of money yeah cuz I know people
who were not in the group they would not
join because they're like maybe I could
make one or two sales here and there and
make some of it back so you know I was
like it's your choice man there's later
they would come back and say hey you
were right about this guy so that's what
happened you know he he promised he
would pay us all back there were 14 of
us who were included in this agreement
and it was two hundred eighty seven
thousand dollars he made he we start we
argued a bit about the terms like when
should it start and we settled on
February we didn't have a completely
signed agreement but it was signed by
him and sent to us which we revised and
sent back to him but then he was like
he didn't he didn't sign that one so but
we were like okay we're expecting this
payment just so you know in February and
it was $2,500
it's not a lot for him because we were
expecting to get like 10,000 a month
basically because we didn't want to take
forever on this thing there's there's
only so much we were willing to take
but $2,500 right now as a you know good
faith show of a you know show of good
faith basically so he pays that late and
then he's like okay I'm liquidating my
business it's all going wait that was it
then he I don't understand what he was
doing what did he think he was achieving
by that he gave us $2,500 you know
that's like a hundred and twenty dollars
maybe he felt that was his way of paying
penance for taking $300,000 she's like
I'll pay them back 1% of what I took for
them yeah I know I I don't know and then
then he has these videos later you know
because we're still watching him but he
has these videos of these these very
expensive vacations he took with his
wife and his family in Thailand in the
EMS photos of his wife's massage parlor
and like these videos of his apartment
really lavish places you know exhort
resorts these exotic resorts in Thailand
ruined it was just is in your face you
know yeah yeah of him using and using
the money you gave him to go lavishly
spend it I mean what can you do though
like the guy does not live in America
even if he did getting your money back
even from people in America is extremely
tough just people don't understand that
contracts aren't worth what you think
they're worth it money-back guarantees
aren't worth what you think you're worth
what matters is who hold
the money and when somebody at when you
hand that money over to someone else
they've got you they have got you okay
so let's let's start wrapping this up so
because I think we've run the gamut of
you getting involved you losing all this
money you sort of waking up you trying
to get your money back unable to get
your money back
Jimmy Crangle sort of just disappears
into the smoke and I guess what are you
taking away from this that I mean
obviously there's no way to get your
money back but I'll have you sort of
obviously you're speaking out to try to
help other people but what what else you
trying to do whatever else at what else
have you learned you know I've learned
not to trust somebody I I saw this quote
if it was like from Aristotle or
something but don't trust a man who
urges an action for which he takes no
risk so that is yet part in this yeah he
took no risk in this so there is no
reason that he should honor his
agreements you know I can't believe I
couldn't see it earlier I felt so dumb I
was like okay now but now I know and
I've you know I can see through all of
this stuff now I feel like I'm never
this is never gonna happen again that's
for sure
but I just feel it's really important
for people to know that this kind of
thing happens it's not just these fake
gurus who promise you you're going to
learn something from them that will make
you a million dollars some people
actually claim they have a working
business model that can make you rich
right now
the fake gurus do that Kevin yeah Oh
Kevin
we'll have to mute that we have a Valda
Mork says that Amazon FBA is the working
business model that's so easy so future
proof so perfect that you should get
involved so a lot of people do that this
is not uncommon
Emma limbs are a great example
multi-level marketing is a great example
of people who are constantly saying hey
you can make all this money you can make
all this money foolproof
proven system proven I can't tell you
how many times I've heard that idiotic
line and it's absolutely not
it's absolutely not true so no not
uncommon I think people just have to
realize and appreciate how much their
mind will convince them because they so
badly want it to be true they so badly
want it to be true that for $30,000 you
can start making $100,000 a year yep
right yeah yeah that that's exactly what
I felt and I I think it's important for
for people to just be aware of the the
the scale of this thing and and all of
the things you know because there's so
many gurus out there this guy is not
even known in the West and he scammed
people out of probably over a million
dollars I can't say for sure but that's
that's such a good point okay well if
you thought like I did when you first
heard the story who's Jimmy Crangle well
richer than me are you guys and we don't
even know about he's not even a big guru
if that guy is making this amount of
money by you know over-promising
under-delivering whatever you want to
call it scamming people as you said what
what are these big gurus doing what are
these gurus who their brand names almost
at this point right what are the Dan
locks the world's doing what are what
are the valta morts of the world doing
in terms of numbers in terms of number
of people that maybe don't get what
they're promised mm-hmm yeah you know I
want to be I want people to be aware of
this cuz you can get sucked in so easy
and it has profound implications on your
life with me an $80,000 is no joke it's
it's caused you to get a new career have
to change your career it's you know
affected everything right yeah yeah you
know I was determined to make it because
at the time when I moved back to the US
I was like I gotta go stay with my
grandparents again just so I can you
know find my footing was then at that
point that's when the business failed
and I realized what I was involved in
it's like I'm gonna have to stay here
forever I was like there's no way so you
know I'm 30 years old
I need to get out and get on my own so I
just I was living in poverty for a few
months you know I got a cheap apartment
and bought a car because I was back in
the u.s. I had to get everything set up
again and I started going to school and
working part-time just to make enough
money and fortunately I've been able to
make enough money to support myself so
you know things are things are turning
around I want to say because two
thousand eighteen and nineteen was a big
downward slide and from the top to the
bottom just straight down well I I love
your attitude I mean I think you have a
really good attitude for the hand you've
been dealt and it's clear to me that you
know given your work ethic you're gonna
eventually rise back up but people do
have to appreciate I mean the amount of
years it sets you back in terms of where
you were where you are now what your
what your abilities are now because you
just don't have the money that you did
as you spent it all in this guy so I
think that about covers it I don't wanna
to rehash too much I think those are
some good final thoughts from you Levi
thank you so much seriously for coming
on the show people it is not easy to
talk about losing $50,000 on the
internet to thousands tens of thousands
of people so please show some love to
Levi in the comments section and yeah if
you have a similar story you'd like to
share it get it out there I'm telling
you guys this makes a difference it it
shows people the architecture of these
things and when they see it I mean I get
fan mail all the time or maybe it's just
thang-thang mail because they just hey I
was about to buy this course I watch one
of your videos I realized I was falling
for something that wasn't the jet and
that's the best thing we can do here is
prevent future people from getting
involved in these and these ridiculous
operations and wasting time and money
yeah thank you so much Levi
thank you coffee like Stephen like you
know what you do is invaluable I've
never seen anybody do
anything like this before is like I see
people like Tai Lopez I'm like when are
some but when is somebody gonna call
these people out and I don't want to
point fingers again but you know you've
called so many people out and that just
it just provides something that was
never there that I've never found before
so thank you absolutely absolutely
appreciate your time preciate you man
talk to you guys later
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]